يعني يبدو ان هذه التظاهره تركزت في بغداد
من جميع المحافظات العراقيه جاءت هذه
الاعداد التي تشاهدونها هنا والتي تجمعت
في الطريق القريب جدا من البنك المركزي
مبنى البنك المركزي هذا هو شارع الرشيد
الذي نتواجد فيها لحاليا ومن خلفنا ايضا
اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين ومن ثم بنايه
البنك المركزي العراقي التي تمنع فيه قوات
مكافحه الشغب طبعا المتظاهرين عبر وضعها
السكن الشائكه واعداد كبيره ايضا منهم
تمنع اي احد من الاقتراض من المبنى بعد
التفاهم طبعا مع قاده هذه التظاهره الى
الان هذه الاعداد ما تزال تتواجد هناك
جاءت من عدد من المحافظه من العراقيه
رسالتها واضحه هي الاعتراض على ارتفاع سعر
صرف الدولار امام الدينار بهذا الشكل
وبالتالي الامر هذا ادى الى ارتفاع اسعار
البضائع والسلع والمواد الغذائيه
هذا الامر هو الذي دفعها هؤلاء الى
التظاهر ومطالبه الحكومه وحتى البرلمان
باتخاذ اجراءات عاجله
لحل هذه الازمه اما عن الوقت الذي ستستمر
فيه هذه التظاهره معنا الان ابو سماح
الدويتشي الذي جاء من النجف يتحدث الينا
الى متى تستمر والله احنا بالنسبه لنا
محافظه النجف الاشرف لغرض همم خفض سعد
الدولار من 163 الى 120 وقررنا ان نعطسهم
في شارع الرشيد مقابل البنك المركزي
العراقي
همم
لخفض سعر الدولار وهذه رساله الى الحكومه
الحكومه السودان محمد اشاعه السودان يعني
بالضبط على الكتل الاكبر وضغط على الاحزاب
يعني الغرض همم وضغط على البنك المركزي
للتخفيض سعر الدولار
شكرا اذا الرساله واضحه رسالتها هؤلاء
المتواضعين ااا يعني انا انا اريد ان
اسالك يعني وتنظيم اعتصام على ما يبدو منذ
ان ارتفع سعر
الدولار طبعا امام الدينار العراقي كيف
انعكس ذلك على حياه المواطنين العراقيين
يعني همم يعني كيف رصدتها فيما يخص تضخم
الاسعار وغيره همم ما الذي فرصته خلال
الايام الماضيه
يعني ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار ادى الى
اشتعال الاسعار الاسعار المواد الغذائيه
الرئيسيه وحتى الخضار وبالتالي انعكس حتى
على بقيه المواد الاخرى حتى مواد البناء
وصولا الى جميع المستلزمات التي يحتاجها
العراقيون هذا الامر شكل ضغطا طوال
الاسابيع الثمانيه الماضيه وحتى هذا اليوم
على على الاسواق هناك ما يشبه الركود في
الاسواق عدم اقبال على شراء البضائع
بالتالي سبب شللا همم كبيرا للحياه هنا
الحياه التجاريه في العصر بغداد وبقيه
المحافظات العراقيه همم هنا ايضا معنا احد
المتظاهرين نود الى متى ستستمرون الى متى
سريع المنتظر ستواصلون هذا الاعتصام سلام
عليكم الناشط المجيد احمد
يا حكومه
احنا جايين طالب مدارس طالب غذائيه جاء
طالب
ضمان صحي ضمان الاجتماعي الدولار مجتمع
كامل دمر العراق